what's up y'all we're back and our next
guest stars in the peabody nominated
netflix series created by mindy kaling
it's called never have i ever check it
out
is this a head shot wow l.a trash is
depressing
i know i think i saw a silicone breast
implant
wow so about yesterday i
thought about what you said and i'm in
i'd like to be your girlfriend so if you
don't kill each other i think it could
be really nice
yeah yeah okay
all right y'all please say hello to
jerry lawson
[Music]
it's so good to meet you too thank you
for having me hey everybody so excited i
love having fellow texans
oh my god i know where were you born in
texas yes so i was born in north dallas
and i actually lived there most of my
life
yeah but i'm not like a super country
boy i'm definitely more of a city kid
but if it counts my school did have a
country western dance team
if that makes yeah if that gives you any
country points you know
it is funny though because i tell people
anytime i'm like oh i'm from fort worth
i was born and forth they'll be like oh
i've been to dallas i'm like that's
really different
kind of kind of different for sure it's
really different yeah i mean i know that
we're like you know 30 minutes apart but
it is funny because it i do feel like
people are more city like i think like
fort worth now it's more of a metropolis
when i whenever i grow up there because
i'm like a lot older than you
but i just mean it's different now but
no it is it is very much the opposite
side of the tracks but i love dallas
they have great food
yeah the food's so good fort worth
actually i love
the arts festival they have like a lot
of cool stuff my favorite barbecue
places in fort worth oh wait what
have you ever been to cooper's barbecue
no okay so it's easy to live there in a
minute okay
do you know where billy bob's is have i
performed there yes
of course i love billy bob so i've never
gotten to go to billy bob's but right
next door is cooper's
oh it's my favorite barbecue i always
judge barbecue by the brisket
yeah and then they're famous for the rib
eye so if you ever
go like kelly i'm telling you it's
unreal
it's so good i love it okay well
speaking of food yeah um i have yet to
find good queso in this
city have you no no okay if you find
good queso
like literally i'll drive an hour i
can't find it also cream cheese with
salsa what
i've actually never tried you should do
it and you're welcome okay
um trust texans we like food um so
what's new
season two of never have i ever yeah so
season one if you guys haven't seen
it's based on events from mindy kaling's
life and it centers around davey vishwa
kumar who is played by maitreya
ramakrishnan
and it basically goes through high
school and it's got so many different
types of characters and so much
diversity within it so for season two we
really dive into kind of the
complexities of those characters
everybody has something in season two
that's so interesting and complex and
different we have
you know different identity crisis and
and people are finding themselves in
different ways you have
family dynamics and for me for ben gross
my character if you guys haven't seen
season one
i would skip this next 20 seconds but it
ends with
me ben gross and davey making out in a
car
so it's you know been coming for all
these years they've really been getting
closer
and season two dives into pressure yeah
they dive into more of that relationship
and kind of you know different aspects
of their
blossoming romance and all that kind of
stuff it's uh
it's a wild ride so i would definitely
say that you all have to tune in to find
out because uh
there's some pretty crazy stuff y'all
that's a pretty crazy i mean it i
almost spoiled too much but you know i
have to ask though is it nerve-wracking
like the first time you kissed someone
on screen as
nerve-wrecking as it is in real life you
know it's like a different kind of
nerves
like my first kiss in real life
coincidentally they were both in a car
my first kiss in real life and on
twitter that's also very texan yeah
yeah i know my mom no chance like i was
not gonna be in my house
um but i was in a car and i was so
nervous that like
the girl i was with i think she leaned
in ninety percent
i maybe had the last ten and like as we
were kissing i was thinking to myself
you didn't even meet her halfway
oh my god no too nervous yeah no i was
like i can't get like that i'm like i
had no i was literally just staring
like this just like i couldn't even look
at her because i was so scared
because i didn't know what i was doing
and i was like i remember thinking like
while we were kissing like how do you
breathe yeah and what why why are you
searching for something in the back of
my throat with your tongue yes yeah i
was like what is going on right now
it's a lot of tongue actually i hated my
first kiss mine was actually pretty
funny
i was not i'm so jealous yeah okay i'm
sorry to hear that
but you know my first on screen kiss was
great though i felt like
besides the 45 people that are watching
you and making it
like oh hey crew what's going on it's
for the most part i felt like it was
really calm it was it was really you
know intimate even though there's a lot
of people around
yeah i felt like for our characters it
was such a big moment and i think that
it really translated how comfortable we
felt and the tone
you know i felt like was really correct
and it just it made me feel really
confident and excited because i felt
like so many of the fans like
loved it and created this love triangle
with team paxton and team ben
and it's just it was super exciting to
be able to kind of pull that off i guess
it's kind of easier because you are
playing a character so it's like
this is how my character kisses yeah for
sure so like if you're bad it's like oh
that's the character
definitely you should see my real work
exactly um
well everybody never have i ever
returned this month to netflix
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever